el congreso el tribunal supremo y el
Palacio presidencial de pan alto en la
capital Brasilia una marea humana de
manifestantes irrumpió en los
principales lugares de poder de Brasil
son partidarios del expresidente
ultraderechista Jair bolsonaro una
semana después de la investidura del
presidente izquierdista Lula siguen
rechazando la elección del nuevo
mandatario en las redes sociales
impactantes imágenes han circulado que
recuerdan a la invasión del Capitolio en
Washington en enero de 2021 los videos
muestran despachos parlamentarios
deteriorados o manifestantes de pie en
los escaños del hemiciclo del senado en
una declaración pública al presidente
Lula pidió la intervención federal y
prometió que se encontraría y castigaría
a los responsables
quería decirles que todas las personas
que hicieron esto serán encontradas y
castigadas
se darán cuenta de que la democracia
garantiza el derecho a la libertad y a
la libre expresión
pero la democracia también exige que las
personas respeten las instituciones
la zona donde se encuentran los
edificios de poder había sido acordonada
por la policía pero los bolsonaristas
lograron romper los cordones de
seguridad horas después del ataque la
policía retomó el control total de la
situación
desde la derrota del ultraderechista
bolsonaro el 30 de octubre sus
seguidores estaban acampando frente a
cuarteles militares exigiendo la
intervención del ejército para destituir
al presidente de izquierda Jair
bolsonaro que nunca felicitó a Lula por
su elección y huyó su investidura
abandonó Brasil dos días antes del final
de su mandato y se encuentra en Estados
Unidos